Speaker 1: All right. Let's now move from the
Sebastian Gorka program to truth Essential Trump
on his social media platform melting down because
Fox News is spreading Ron DeSantis propaganda.
Now, I'll be honest. Fox News is spreading Ron
DeSantis propaganda. Trump's not wrong about that.
What's funny is he doesn't seem to get that Fox
News. His priority here is to maintain access to
power, whoever ends up holding the power. And so,
yes, Fox News does seem to have a preference for
DeSantis, but they're not going to abandon Trump.
If Trump wins the first couple of primaries,
Fox News will be back to Trump and eating out
of his hand. That's all Fox cares about. Here
is what Trump posted the truth social, saying,
quote, Fox News is promoting Ron Desanctis so
hard and so much that there's not much time left
for real news. There was never real news on Fox,
but okay. Reminds me of 2016 when they
were pushing Jeb. The new Fox poll,
which have always been purposely terrible
for me, has Trump crushing the sanctimonious,
but they barely show it. Instead, they go
with the losers like Karl Rove, Paul Ryan,
and now even Jasper, who have been wrong about
everything. Isn't there a big, beautiful capital
and network which wants to do well and make a
fortune besides fake news? Now, as a reminder,
here's the promo. This is unabashed Ron DeSantis
propaganda. Here's a promo for the show. Fox Did
Fox Nation's hit docu series is back.
Who is Ron DeSantis? We will never,
ever surrender to the woke up.
Unidentified: We're going to die.
He was in the.
Speaker 1: Middle East advising SEAL.
Speaker 4: Team one to advise them. You have
to be the best of the best. He's a good man.
He's a good husband. He's a good father.
Is this Ron DeSantis whose opportunity
to run for higher office? I think it is.
Speaker 1: Who is Ron DeSantis streaming now?
Yeah, this is the epitome of of news tainment,
right? I mean, this is this is not meant to be
informative. This is supposed to be entertaining
to the Fox News audience, and it is overt
propaganda. So Trump isn't wrong to be posting
about that. Lastly, Trump then posting about
polls. Trump crushes DeSantis in Fox News poll.
And again, it is not untrue. When you look at the
polling data right now, when you have multi-way
polls, meaning Trump, DeSantis, Haley, Tim Scott,
Mike Pence, Mike Pompeo, and whoever else Trump
does quite well when it is Trump versus DeSantis
head on, it is much less good for Donald. Trump.
And so Trump is not wrong about that. We are
going to continue following the polling, but most
importantly, we are going to continue following
the growing civil war within the Republican
Party. Related to this, CPAC starts tonight,
the Conservative Political Action Conference. It's
going to be a pretty low end CPAC because CPAC
organizer Matt SCHLAPP has been accused of groping
a male staffer despite being anti-gay personally.
And this seems to have led to a lot
of no's for people who haven't been
invited to CPAC. We are going to start our
live coverage of CPAC tonight on YouTube,
Twitter and Facebook. So I hope you will tune in
to that and my curiosity about this year's CPAC,
this year's first CPAC. They seem to do it five
times a year now. Is going to be do they take any
kind of overt position on the 2024 Republican
primary? Does CPAC remain overtly pro-Trump?
Does CPAC become agnostic or do they pretend
there is no primary going on? Is it just up
to whoever speaks? One of the opponents of
Trump, Vivek Ramaswamy, whose campaign is
not exactly launched with much fanfare. He is
actually going to be a speaker at CPAC. So it's
going to be a very interesting thing to see.
It will be live starting tonight on YouTube,
Twitter and Facebook. I hope you will join me. And
remember, you can get it all truly get it all on
the main YouTube channel, YouTube.com slash The
David Pakman Show. If you are not yet subscribed,
please subscribe. Folks, this is my Jeb
Bush. Please clap moment. Please subscribe.